If you want to change someone’s behavior,
you can do two things.
You can go four layers deep into their dreams
on a daring and deadly raid to plant an idea.
Or you can like… flip a switch I guess.
Hi independent thinkers, Julian here for DNews.
You are the master of your mind, right?
You make your own decisions and nobody and
nothing can make you do anything you don’t
want to do.
Well I have bad news for you; that might not
be true in the future.
Researchers at the University of Massachusetts
medical school have managed to alter the behavior
of nematodes by directly reprogramming one
neuron.
The nematode C. elegans is a tiny roundworm
that lives in soil.
It crawls about, moving its head from side
to side to feel out its environment.
But it has a very clever enemy.
A carnivorous fungus that forms small loops
like nooses.
When the C. elegans pokes its head through,
the noose tightens, breaking the cuticle of
the worm and letting the fungus feast on the
insides.
C. elegans has developed a counter to this
deadly noose.
There’s a small delay before the noose tightens,
and if they back away quickly while keeping
their head straight, they can escape.
For this reason, when the nematode is touched
just behind the head, it will do exactly that.
It won’t back up this way if you touch it
anywhere else, like on the tail or even the
nose.
With that in mind, Dr. Mark Alkema set out
to see if he could quite literally reprogram
the worm’s behavior.
C. elegans is the only animal to date that’s
had its entire brain mapped.
It’s only got 302 neurons making 7000 connections,
so it was the ideal candidate for the first
connectome.
A connectome is the name for that fully mapped
neural network.
Because everything is plotted out, the complete
path of this defense against fungus is known,
from sensory neuron to interneuron to motor
neuron.
So Dr. Alkema decided to see if changing how
one of those neurons fired changed behavior.
His team swapped out a neuron’s inhibitory
channel with an excitatory one.
Now when the engineered C. elegans felt something
behind its head it no longer backed up, but
pressed on while contracting its head.
It would still fall victim to the noose though,
rendering its survival mechanism moot.
Changing how one little neuron worked completely
changed behavior, while still keeping the
rest of the worm’s brain stable and functioning.
This has implications far beyond keeping fungus
fed.
The idea of a connectome has long been the
subject of debate.
Detractors of it pointed to the nematodes
and said, “Yeah that’s cool and all, but
can you actually do anything with it?”
Because of that, mapping neurons of much larger
brains like ours, with our 86 billion neurons
and 100 trillion synapses, seemed like a fool’s
errand.
It would be costly, time consuming, and ultimately
useless.
Now however it’s been shown that knowing
exactly how behavior flows through the brain
means we can direct that flow.
If we have a complete map of a human brain,
think of the implications.
Maybe we can write out behavioral disorders
like ADHD, or finally rewire that brain failure
that makes people play their music out loud
on public transit.
What a wonderful world that would be.
But until that day comes, you’ll just have
to change hearts and minds the old fashion
way: by getting your thoughts and story out
there.
Which you could do on your very own` website.
And no domain extension will help you tell
your story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain
name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
Another challenge to making connectomes is
the brain’s neuroplasticity.
The brain is a pretty amazing thing and it
adapts and rewires itself.
Trace talks about how brains adapt in amazing
ways here.
Connectomes of complex creatures like us would
be tough to pull off, do you think it’d
be worth it to engineer behavior?
Is engineering behavior even ethical?
Let us know in the comments or on facebook
or twitter, subscribe for more, and I’ll
see you next time on DNews.